foreign
another question here this one is from
Nova on Facebook I have an art studio
that uses a lot of physical materials
what's the best way to organize art
supplies when you don't have much
storage now Kristen you do a great job
of organizing the things that are
essential as opposed to organizing
everything and then just uh you know
clearing the space of the Clutter but
retaining the Clutter when I look at
your space whether it's your pantry or
just your home in general recognize that
people often need supplies especially
for someone like Nova and she has a lot
of physical materials art supplies
What's um what are some techniques that
you use to organize a lot of these
things so they don't become clutter a
lot of our clients are artists because
their work actually does require a lot
of materials and tools so we're not
going to say well you need to just get
rid of it all you know because then they
wouldn't there usually is a little bit
of minimizing and it depends client to
client because it's like oh well you've
had these fabrics for 10 years and let's
pass them on to someone who will use
them and get value from it but this
question reminds me of a client who I
worked with when I was first starting
off and she's a textile artist and when
we came into her Studio
everything was just in piles on the
floor and the studio had 20 foot
ceilings so I said Hey what if we built
shelves and maximize the vertical space
and organized based on the type of
project and all of her tools were
organized by things that cut things that
attached like really simple Concepts not
hyper specific and she was like able to
get so much more done so much more
created
um so yeah I would just say what
opportunities do you have does your
space offer that you might be missing
out on is it vertical space is there a
closet that's got a hanging bar that
maybe you should put shelves in I don't
know without seeing it but I would look
for those opportunities yeah thinking
outside the box we got a friend in uh
Missoula Montana Monty dolac name drop
anyway famous artist
um we go to space all the time he's got
a really pristine clean uh very well
decorated uh house and in his art room
it's so funny because he'll take us back
there all the time like to show us what
he's working on and he's always
apologizing for all of his art supplies
I'm like dude you're an artist and on
top of it he hasn't organized so well
and he is like thought outside of the
box with all of his uh supplies and how
he organizes them so like he has the
mechanics tool drawers that he organizes
a lot of that stuff he has filing
cabinets where he keeps um like
different magazines and he has them like
perfectly filed like alphabetical order
it would be like if Joshua Fields
Melbourne was an artist like this would
be his his system but what I really
appreciate about him is he's always
questioning like do I need all of this
stuff yeah and sometimes he's like yeah
he'll you know see a stack of pictures
or whatever it is and he's like you know
what I'm not gonna I'm not going to use
that in the end in the future anytime
soon so he gets rid of it so it's about
I mean yeah thinking outside the box but
also being able to realize when you do
have too much and being able to let go
and figure out what you can let go of
when you're you're feeling overwhelmed
and quite often there are supplies that
we need to organize people often think
I'm against The Container Store just
because I well I I will bash the fact
that we often go there as if it is the
solution to our clutter no that's it if
you have a bunch of clutter The
Container Store isn't going to really
help at all however if you have a bunch
of things that actually need to be
organized art supplies things that you
actually use then it can be a wonderful
way to sort through those things in an
organized fashion that looks good it's
calm it's peaceful but the opposite is
not true if you don't have all those
supplies and you go buy the bins
remember we watch that video a few
months ago where it was this like Tick
Tock video and it was a storage solution
for garages and this is a bunch of bins
that go on the ceiling basically and at
first I saw that I'm like oh that looks
great I could use I'm like wait a minute
what I'd have to buy things and then put
into those bins right and so that might
work really well for someone who needs
to store a bunch of things on the roof
of their garage but for me it would just
be a bunch of empty bins it wouldn't
make any sense because I got rid of the
things that would otherwise be stored in
those maybe at your neighbor's house
one day he's gonna go to his neighbors
be like hey man can I borrow that again
you should show him the solution and be
like hey
this will really help you out be way
more aesthetically pleasing for me
[Laughter]
Kristen at what point do you go do you
take a client to a place like The
Container Store and help them organize
their things I think about this because
yesterday Bex was doing our monthly sort
of decluttering and she's getting rid of
that I think she knew you were going to
be here I don't want to be judged and so
she's getting rid of of random things
which I'm always grateful for anytime
she gets rid of something especially
when it's not mine
I feel great about that right but also I
even recognize in our home there's
probably a place for more sort of bins
or organization systems that would
benefit us we've gotten down to this
Minima and
um and now it's like okay maybe adding a
few organizing elements would actually
increase the peace or the calm in that
space yeah it's definitely a different
balance in each space but
um the point at which we would go to The
Container Store similar is at the end of
the process we never show up with
contain owners because oftentimes we're
able to repurpose what the client
already has or there's just really no I
think yeah I think people get really
overwhelmed going to places like The
Container Store because they think that
it's the solution
um and there's just no way to know what
you actually need until you've sorted
and minimized at the same time you don't
want to open up a closet that you have
minimized and have everything crash out
ever you know because it's not contained
and it's loose
um so yeah I think at the end if needed
oftentimes we have things that we can
repurpose so um
yeah don't start with because then
you're hiding the Clutter but now if
you're truly organizing what remains
everything that remains yeah that's
great but in the meantime the
limitations sort of breed creativity you
might realize like all the things I was
gonna hide in those containers maybe I
don't need them at all did you enjoy
this Standalone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free